all right I don't want it to be the
focus but I what's going on here sharing
what Sherwood's exchanging fluids it's
like coffee I hope so he said look like
that I cook I matter what that code yeah
neither and i'm not talking about no
one's guy okay well actually i might be
turning on talking about how much guy so
last week the i guess there was a you
know early version of the game sent out
to press there was a leak there was all
this there was no copy said it was no
press ok we paid over one hundred
dollars to have a copy overnighted to us
from york oh really wonderful yeah so
you played a bunch of the game pre this
I guess 1.03 patch which came as on
Monday there was a big read me the charm
or ii wrote about us adding quite a lot
of content to it so i guess i want to
ask you about the sort of main
differences between the game that we all
saw on launch and that experience
because it's sort of like a weirdly
fascinating insight into day one patches
and how much you can fundamentally
change the game right mere hours before
i came out so what were some of the big
differences that you experienced between
those two versions so the two big ones
for me i'll start with the first which
is your inventory and how much a single
unit can hold in terms of resources raya
so one slot in your inventory can hold
before the patch it was a hundred units
of a specific material and that was the
same for your ship as it was for your
exosuit now your ship can hold 500 per
unit and your exes 2 can hold 250 per
unit that's only out that's an insane
yeah my inventory is constantly full i
couldn't but five times more that's
that's not right so that makes the
process of mining a much more gratifying
thing because you know i'm not just
getting a little bit of wealth i'm
getting wealthy like i'm collecting a
lot of stuff and I'm goin back Mike
offers full to trade in that seems like
a crazy balance change yeah it hasn't
really impacted the like the bigger
picture actions and I'm taking in terms
of jumping solar systems and stuff like
that it's mostly the moment to moment so
I don't think I don't think of it as
dramatic I just think of it as nice to
have that's not so I saw a lot of
quality of life sort of stuff rob was
down
about yeah about like for instance in
the menus you couldn't just hit back you
couldn't just hit circle you'd have to
yeah for every action you choosing a
menu you have to hold down the X button
with a cursor over a menu option to exit
out you used to have to do that as well
now you can just hit circle that's not
but it got even worse like when you were
comparing you know if you were talking
to a traitor and you're like maybe I
want to buy your ship now when you look
at their ship it tells you the price and
then there's an option to compare what
items each ship has before it didn't
show you the price so you automatically
had to go to that second menu need to
get out of that you ought you had to do
that holding down the cursor again so
it's a lot more efficient in that sense
in that ensures sean's em read me or is
that his dog plan I guess and he also
talked about how the three paths there
were three unique paths to pay through
the game and they sort of like served
these up in a more and I guess literal
sort of sense did you was the start of
the game much difference or the way the
the start of the game was pretty similar
the game basically guides you into
accessing your hyperdrive which lets you
jump from solar system in the solar
system and then it kind of frees you up
to do what you want you make a decision
the moment you start the game which is
your you sort of see this distress
beacon and it's it belongs to Atlas or
the Atlas movement and you decide to
activate it and somehow become in tune
with it that remains the same but
eventually once you get your hyperdrive
it's sort of like all right you go to
your map there are two options free
exploration or the path to the center of
the galaxy but the more you start
playing you start to you know if you
activated that distress speaking at the
beginning Atlas will reach out to you
and say hey your destiny lies in the
stars so that is zima that says activate
your hyperdrive so when you do that and
you go up into the Galactic map you know
with all the solar system's it then says
hey atlas has something for you over
here then again that's not really
towards the center of the galaxy and so
then you can choose to follow that stuff
it's interesting apparently the whole
thing was rewritten as well and James
swallow was when the writer on deus ex
yeah himself and sean murray basically
rewrote the entire atlas path as well
between these patches that's pretty odd
to nuts you know i read that i forgot
about it i'm glad to hear that actually
is a path and not just a meandering
circling the drain so it's
the Atlas path just going straight to
the center as fast as possible with the
third I don't know so the third are yeah
that's not it yeah it's not i might I
thought I meters missed it so you can
you can retreat it off his update as he
mentions it there i don't actually can
actually see it here on this update it's
the same and someone we sort of alluded
to earlier it's the other names right
yeah it's these two travelers that are
they have a lot of higher learning under
their belt and they're very smart and
experienced and you encounter them once
in a while now it's not can I have an in
Canada man I only heard about them but I
haven't actually seen the man they
present you with I think for options to
aid your quest whatever it may be and I
think it allows you to pivot as well so
if you want to change your direction and
say maybe I don't want to do Alice
anymore and what is other thing it'll
give you an incentive to make that not
like a really difficult decision ok but
I but somehow you can follow them as
well and that's not totally clear to me
at this point how you do that a lot of
other additions to the game including
just more variety apparently like
terrain generation the atmospheres of
planets planets themselves the diversity
of the creatures around either there was
no feeding before all the social service
feeding oh no maybe animals didn't feed
maybe they didn't have like the ecology
or something there I think what you can
do now is you can feed them a specific
element all right thank you huh that
just sounds cruel in some cases give
them like radio time you know I think
for a forget how it works but
essentially I think they laid out the
fact if you give them the certain
element will befriend you versus just
not yeah be hostile or they poop
something out Boop I keep hearing that
they might poop poop something I think
those Colombian cats not to go off topic
why coffee with a feed the cat oh yeah
yeah sorry anyway just porn uh um but
won't II the other changes that's really
nice is they let you scan the terrain
from your ship right where you would
have to land to scan or use your eyes
but because of the draw distance it's
hard to really use visual scanning
method that's insane you couldn't do
that from the ship before yeah so you
would have to land and then and you
couldn't do it in outer space either you
go so you would essentially just yeah
that's not so it's made a lot of things
easier apparently one of the things I
did notice as well at least from the
traitor
reason from the version I playing is
that the amount of pop in and
artifacting that happens I mean it's
still there it's still there you know
it's there and in there and it reminds
me of like GTA 4 swear it was like there
all the time we kind of got used to it
yeah it's no raining or severe i think
is what it was previously at least in
like I noticed it immediately and I was
like yeah this is this is better and
when I just now it just feels normal
yeah miss Dawson poppin but ah so do you
think interesting that all this is it a
worry to you and you see like all of
this crazy stuff getting rushed into a
game last minute and now no this is just
a reality of going gold that like yes
this many boxes printed you need to yeah
it's the reality of having someone
publisher game right there's a really
interesting uh you read that blog post
Remy Remy yes yes yeah really about like
what going gold really means and what it
doesn't mean as much we thought it would
how like hello games are still
essentially working the same hours in
the last minutes go ahead well and
they're beholden to a dead you know an
outdated system basically we're looking
published by themselves on Steam and
control how all of that rolls out
console makers have to you know this
unspoken quality seal of quality and
like all this and that that like
publishers expect games to meet that and
it's does all sorts of milestones and we
were business stuff that involved we had
a Rob and I did a trip recently down to
another studio and one of the heads the
studio was saying like yeah hopefully
later this week will will pass cert
whatever that means anymore so I was
like what are you talking about this
before like the no man's sky stuffing
yeah yeah you can pick that up on rami
ismail calm as well that bloggers pretty
good or am i is ma IL ya fascinating
read uh crazy i guess that like they
were working on this up the upon till
launch and would continue to work on it
yeah but i looked at the credits on the
game and it's nuts because it's
basically one page it's like 20 odd
people yeah who work at hello games then
the next page is like a couple of people
to when you used like they're they're
all PR managers on there and a couple of
other people like they're saying thank
you to and then it's like 10 pages of
sony yeah this like a QA and like biz
dev and like every single like adam
boyes is on that like every person who
was even
touched a sony products name is on it
and yeah it really shows you this team
with this game was made by a tiny like a
very food for the type of game it is
especially considering none of them have
really made a game like this like
they're all you know they made Joe
Danger previously they've all worked on
bigger games like Burnett and stuff like
that working in sort of the wider
society england game development world
but yeah it's not what's really exciting
for me is that they have gotten to the
point to release this game and what that
means is they're offering what they
promised now they get to deliver on the
things they didn't promise because they
didn't know if they could pull it off do
you think they're gonna add to it the
art the next to did the next update that
they said is gonna have is gonna let you
build your own outposts already in
freighter ships what really yes you're
going to have permanent pets like
they're going to keep adding today
somebody asked me on twitter or didn't
hit the lab building out bugs i was like
nah i don't i probably won't want to i
hate it in fallout but like I'm just I'm
just super stoked that okay the lattice
is there now they can just keep tacking
things onto it and hopefully they work
and make it great yeah I think thought
about the fact that this is like
minecraft one point out yeah I'm a they
got to yeah add to it interesting stuff